Hey fellas. Hi, man. You guys look rested. Yeah, I'm feeling pretty good. Did you have nice dreams last night? I'm feeling a little sick. Huh. Talking to Will mostly. Sorry. Yeah, he looks great. Yeah. Will, you must have had some nice dreams, huh? I've had some really, some really sweet dreams. You remember them? You got a little, you got a little log book next to your bed? Yeah, I like to wake up and jot them down. And I just sort of jot them down and a lot of them and then I wake up and it's usually like math equations. Oh. Yeah. You figure a lot of stuff out while you're sleeping. Yeah, yeah, I just figured a lot of stuff out. You're crunching numbers, right? Oh, here, like this one, if I do,
I wrote this one. Why? And you've moved the equals to the power. Basically translation is welcome to wireless. Oh, great. Look at this. Look at this guy. Which guy? This guy. Ricky's got that. Is that Robbie? It's Ricky. Hey, Robbie. Ricky. His name's Ricky. Yeah, I know. Look at the size of this cone around his head. That looks like an expensive cone. Usually you just see just a regular plastic one that's kind of cloudy and you've got a fabric cone. Look at him. Look at his look on his face. He's got a, he had a, like a cyst, like a big bump, like a big ball on his butt. Like, uh, like, uh, oh, here we go. Yeah. Will. I can hear Will's cogs turning, writing something. No, hurtful. No. Why would I exist on his, on his, like bottom and they
gouged it out and so he has to wear this big cone. Speaking of balls on your bum, Jay, how's your weekend been? So they cut, so they cut, so they removed the balls from his bottom. Yeah. Like that. It was a big cyst on his tail. Gouged it out. And he was still able to get around there and, uh, and chew it, lick it, kind of agitate it. It was crazy. Yeah. Any chance he got. And so they put the cone on. How long's the cone been on the dog? About a month. He's got another month to go. Wait a minute. Yeah. It was pretty intense. I've never heard of a cone being on a dog longer than like a few days. Look at this, look at this tail. Oh, you can't see it. I can see it. Oh, I think you might want to look into a different vet, someone that might charge you a
little bit more, but do it right. Yeah. Two months with a cone. Maybe they can make a cone for you that stops you from eating Chinese food. You know what I mean? What would that look like? There's not a big enough one out there. No. No, he had a cone that was too small. So we had to sleep in shifts, Scotty and I, because he would, until we found the right size, because he's like a hundred pounds. I think your vet is really, um, causing you a lot more, a lot more problems than, uh, I know, but we, but we would, we would, um, we'd start, we started watching the crown. So we'd like, we'd watch an episode and then kind of like fall asleep, but we'd poke up and anyway, who cares? Yeah, I don't, uh, about, you didn't even need to speak when you just see it on your face. Don't
worry. So the crown would be your, your, your, your visual ambient. That was, yeah, because like for like a month we had to like sleep in shifts. So we'd, we'd each catch like an episode and then catch the other person up on what that episode is. Well, I sure hope your guest isn't somebody starring on the crown. This is my guest. It's his guest. Oh, it's your, well, I hope your guest is, clearly your guest is not a cast member from the crown. No, but I love the crown. The crown's really good. Why do you use it to fall asleep with them? No, I don't use it to fall asleep. We would, we would, that's what we do in the interim of, of, of swapping out. That's what they do. That's what they do to stay awake. Yeah. Huh. Yeah. The crown. Yeah, it was so good. It's very,
by the way, I'm so late to the party. Like, I know it's like 10 seasons. I'm, I'm even later. I just saw the first three episodes of white lotus finally. Oh, wasn't it good of the first season? The first season. Yeah. And I get it. I'm, I'm, I'm into it. I'm on it. Yeah. Come on in. Well, water's great. It's really, really good. I'm such a contrarian though that I'm like, no, everybody else has seen it. Really? Yeah. What'd you guys do on our little break in between shows? Uh, I made some reviews for white lotus. I just went and wrote scathing reviews, even though I'd never seen it. And I love Mike White. Yeah. Love that, Mike. Now, what'd you do, JB, on your little break ski? I made some oatmeal for my colon. And, and my daughter asked me a
bunch of questions about why I like it and why I told her. And then she tasted, she said, huh, I said, would you like me to make you a bowl? She goes, yes, a small one, please. I made her a bowl of oatmeal and she walked me through all of her studies that she's going through for chemistry right now. She's got a chemistry final coming up. And I never took chemistry in school. No way. Yeah. I don't know. I don't know how or why, um, but, uh, that looks difficult. Yeah. It's in their defense and your school's defense might be dangerous to do chemistry on the, on that bus on Wilshire. Buns and burners and beakers. You know what I mean? I told you that story about my, uh, yeah, you sure did. You don't remember anything, do you? Nope. No. You went to school on a bus,
on a bus, on a, well, just for one year. That was a heartlight one, but, but it was one continuous year. It never stopped moving the bus. It was just one. Well, no, no, those were just on the city days. The city days were on the bus, right? Where we go in and for, for the listener that hasn't heard this before, we, we, we drive the, the base of the school was out at this dude's house in Calabasas, which is out in the deep, deep West Valley, not accredited shocker this school. We would, we'd get on a converted full-size large yellow school bus where the back half of it was converted into desks. Front half was still. Was your driver Charles Manson or? He did smell of weed and patchouli, but I didn't get his name. And then, so we would have these
long drives into city as we go to these cultural places, like museums and whatnot. And the, and the, the hippie that, that started the school thought it might be productive to do schoolwork in traffic while we're on our way to these museums. That's why he converted the bus. So while we're on the venture freeway for an hour and a half, we do schoolwork. And then the country days, the odd days in the week, we'd be out at the house there and Santa in Calabasas. What if Will and I left our little, we were still telling the story. Yeah. No, but there's a teepee. And then on the weekend. Was school was, was, were country days at his house? Was it a lot of like raking,
raking his yard and like vacuuming his living room? You're not far off. We would start each day in the teepee. And then, and then we'd go into his house and you could, you could take history, math or massage. That's a true story. That's not true. Jason, this is creepy. And it was the, there were 20 kids all from like fourth grade to senior in high school. Well, who wouldn't take the massage, by the way? I mean, like you get out of class. The massage class was, was packed. Yeah. It's so creepy. All right. Well, that's why I'm so smart, you guys. Have you ever wondering why? I'm going to get right to our guest who has been so patiently
waiting. She's a very special girl. Really? Yeah. Besides her incredible talent, this woman is often praised for her impeccable style and fashion. She'd said that probably from an early age when she'd borrow her mom's clothing, when she saw her car pull out of the driveway in the morning, she'd borrow the, the clothes ditto. She's one of the co-founders of the times up movement, which she helped kick off at the 2018 Golden Globes the year after she won for best actress in black-ish. You guys, it's Tracy Ellis Ross. Tracy Ellis Ross. Whoa, look at her go. Now, you know, hello there. Listener, she's just wearing a simple blue
sweatshirt, maybe your sweater. And so, so you're, you're known for your styles, but yet you're keeping it very safe. I noticed that with hairdressers that are really good at hair, they're all, they have shaved heads. Well, that's interesting. I will say, I worked, I used to work in fashion. I worked, I was a, hi, all of you. Hi, hi. We'd like to jump right in. Hello. And I did notice back in the day that fashion editors would wear like sort of a blank canvas. Right, just a little uniform. Yeah, it was like, yeah, kind of like a uniform. Something super safe. Well, I feel like if you work in fashion, if you do fashion, if you love fashion, but no, I love the extravagance of it, the glamour.
Yeah, I think I said this before on the, on the, on the show, but not too Tracy. So, but you're so right because I went to this years and years and years ago, I went to Milan to watch this Armani show. And afterwards there was like this party. It's been like going to space for you. Yeah, absolutely. I was like, I have to leave now. And I went to the, then he had like this after party at his house and I asked one of the guys who worked there was like a waiter or something. I'm like, can I go look at his closet? Cause I wanted to see. It was all the same. All the same outfit. All the same outfit. Exactly the same. Yes. Really? 30 of the same outfit. What was the outfit? Black suit. No, well, no, it was a navy t-shirt and jeans.
Interesting. Really? Just a thousand pairs of jeans. There's a lot of freedom in that. Yeah. Yeah. It's like a uniform. Not for me. Serial killers do that too, I think. Yes. That's, that's one of the telltale size of a serial killer. I think Tracy's teacher wore that. The difference with a serial killer will is they don't have multiple pairs. It's just one. Yeah. Just the one. You're right. Nothing that shows blood too well either. You're right. And you just use, it's the same one. But you know what I'm talking about? The guy who's got the, you go to his closet and everything is the exact same. And then they do end up committing, if they, I'm not suggesting Armani did, but if that person, they said,
turns out they were serial killer, we'd say, was there ever any inkling that he would, yes. Yes. It was the first time. There was always an inkling. We never knew. We never knew. Yeah. No, we always knew. Wait, Trace. So first of all, hi, I love you. Wait now. So do you guys know each other? We, we, ish. Yeah. Oh, look at the way. Black ish. No ish. Plug in the show already. No, each other ish. No, each other ish. Should be. No, there's like a connection. There's a spiritual connection. I live for this girl. I love her. I think she's amazing. How did you meet, how did you meet you two?
I'm a Jimmy Kimmel show, but I think we met before that too. When I was the best host, and I, I interviewed you and Jimmy Kimmel. Yep. All right. So listen. So you were, you were born in LA, like, by the way, like Jason was. I was born in LA. Yeah. I did not go to school on a bus. Did not go to school on a bus. Yeah. I was going to get into that. That's what I was going to say. Yeah. There was no massage class. No, no. So I was born here in 1972, actually went to the center way back then, Center for Early Education, before it was this thing that it is now, lived here until my mom was going to New York to do the
whiz. Wow. And then was in New York. Let's make sure the listener knows who mommy was. Barbara Streisand. Wow. Interesting. Diana Ross. Right now, Shawn's sister is like, fucking what? What? Barbara Streisand. Barbara Streisand's daughter is crazy. My mom is Diana Ross. My dad is Bob Ellis Silverstein. Yeah. And was in New York, went to school there until seventh grade, then moved to Paris, because my mom was supposed to do a movie there. She also met her husband, that anyway, whatever, and lived in Paris and went to the American school in Paris for a little while, and then moved to
Switzerland and went to La Rosée and then moved back to the state. And then I, well, you're a Canadian, yeah? Yeah, but I don't speak, okay. Yes. Okay. You speak French. You speak fluent French. Well, I don't know about that. Anyway, sorry, I interrupted you. By the way, it should be pointed out that Tracy, when she goes, and then my mom, just whatever, her whatever's are more interesting than the bulk of my stories. But that's my kind of question is like, because in Chicago, I didn't grow up around, like, you know, in this town, which you're surrounded by fame and all that stuff.
So, so I, you know, I didn't have a sense of other. Well, our senses of other is different, right? It's for opposite reasons. So what was that like as a kid? I wonder. Well, it's all you know. So it's all I knew. The nice thing was that when I went to school, first of all, my mom is a mom before anything else. So she's, I didn't have the sort of fantasy life of what people imagine it would be or what you see in reality shows, for example. That is not, that was not my childhood. Right. And yes, I had incredible opportunity to go to school in Switzerland. I went to the best schools and, you know, Marvin Gaye called our home and all, and Andy Warhol painted me and all these things that are very extraordinary.
I'm looking at, you know, so those things are extraordinary, but because my mom was such a mom, he's in your face right now is amazing. I just think it's so great. So because of all that, but there was a sense of normalcy to my life. And I didn't know there was something different. And then when I went to Dalton in New York, in New York, yeah, the other kids that I was going to school with were Ralph Lauren's kids, Robert Redford's kids. So that was taken off the table for us. So it wasn't a thing. Right. And only as I've gotten, you know, as I became an adult and realized the magnitude of the fact that my mother's an international treasure, as they say, you know, just a goddess of. Well, I mean, you joke about it, but she's an icon.
I'm not joking. No, you're not, but you have to couch it in that. But I have to say, you've achieved the impossible and you're, you're an icon. Like to me, you like, like, you know, the best example I can think of when you watch Janet Jackson, I don't think of Michael Jackson. When you watch Michael Jackson, I don't think of Janet Jackson. When you watch Diana Ross, I think of her, I think of Trace Dallas Ross as two completely different people. And you're surprised to know that, oh, Diana Ross, oh, that's the Ross. Wow. Yeah, it's actually funny. And then when people, you know, I do look a lot like my mom. And then I also look a lot like my dad. But people are surprised and it's fun because they're like,
you didn't tell me. I'm like, why was I supposed to tell you that? Yeah. And we will be right back. SmartList is presented by Nerd Wallet. SmartList listeners, you like to listen to us, even though you understand we are not smart, talented, handsome, sure. But smart is not one of our strong suits. That's where our sponsor comes in. Nerd Wallet, where you can compare top financial products side by side and make smart financial decisions. Nerd Wallet has a whole team of nerds who help you make smart decisions on your next credit card, high yield savings account, and more. And these aren't people who just say they're smart. They're like actual smart. They've got CFPs, MBAs, years of experience, and they're using their expertise to offer side by side
comparisons and objective ratings on top of financial products for you. Are you spending more on gas or groceries lately? Of course you are. The world is terrible. Turn that negative into a positive and find a cashback card that rewards you for what you spend most on. I'm with you, by the way, I spend most probably on gas and groceries. I mean, a lot. I can't not have a cupboard not full of candy. So listeners, it's time to stop being smartList and time to get smart with the nerds at Nerd Wallet. Compare and find top cashback credit card savings account and more at nerdwallet.com. Nerd Wallet, the smartest decision for all your financial decisions. This episode of SmartList is brought to you in part by Macy's. The big game is coming up
and Macy's has everything you need to take you all the way to the end zone. Do you guys get that? They've got all your football fan needs covered with team jerseys, serveware, plus food and snacks that'll keep you cheering. You know what I really love to refresh my serving platter, sitch. I'm getting this thing called the seller. It's like a chip and dip thing. It's called the seller. And I'm getting that. I'm going to dip all my chips and dip in that. And then I'm also getting a new pair of tongs because doesn't everybody need a new pair of tongs because they're a little spring broke on our tongs, a little spring in the middle. They shouldn't like not have those anymore. And when Macy sends it to me, I'm going to say,
tong you very much Macy's. Check it out now at Macy's.com. Again, that's Macy's.com. SmartList is supported by State Farm. There are some great things about being an adult, right? Like you can have ice cream for dinner or the whole week if you really want to. Like I do kind of sometimes not really, but sure I do. Two different colored socks. Why? Go ahead. It's your life. But then there's the other side of it. You know, like adulting and the actual responsibilities that come with it. Working, paying bills, buying a home, the big stuff. There's no instruction manual, you know what I mean for any of it. So figuring it out on your own can get stressful. With State Farm, you can scratch insurance off that list. So when you ask yourself,
what if my policy doesn't cover this? Or what if I have to make a claim in the middle of the night? Or even what if I don't know what something in my policy means? Or like, is that gas? Or is my tummy just upset from all the ice cream I ate? Well, State Farm is there for your what ifs. You can file a claim on the State Farm mobile app, talk to a real person, including your agent, and you can call day or night about insurance coverage and policy questions. State Farm is available 24 seven because that's just what they do. Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. Call or go to statefarm.com for a quote today. All right, back to the show. Wait, so tell me about when you were a kid because I heard this
story once, but it was a while ago that you grew up in a family of five kids or five people. My mom has five kids, but we were three girls with my mom. And then 15 and 16 years later, my brothers were born. And tell me about getting the Wiggles out or something. Oh, yeah. It's Rhonda Tracy, Chedney Ross and Evan just to get through the siblings. And my mom is one of six. So it's a big family, like even just the immediate family is like 22. Everybody, all my siblings have husbands or wives and multiple children. I'm the like lone single lady who, you know, just gets to come and go. What do you think is wrong with you? Sorry. Jesus. Fuck. Sorry. Sometimes there is. Did you, there's a long list. I'm so sorry that
I just said it like that. What you meant was, what you meant was, what I meant was, how's it going? So far, so good. I mean, I just turned 50 and I think I just started working some of this shit out. Oh, believe me. I'm 52 and I am fucking, I am not even close to halfway working out. At 12 years old, I said to my mom, I think I need a therapist. At 12. I wish I'd known. I wish I'd known there was such thing as therapy at that age. I don't know how I knew. Well, you grew up, you grew up in LA, New York. I think that that's kind of stuff. I didn't have sushi until I was 22. Yeah. I love it. That's the marker. I didn't have, I didn't know what to do. I couldn't even think of a fish. Yeah. Nigiri. Okay. Wait. You asked about the Wiggles. Wiggles. Yeah. I was a very
hyperchild and very silly. And I also really loved, it was, my sister, Rhonda is very cerebral and I'm very physical. And so it was really frustrating for my sister, which I thought was very funny. And so I was just very energetic and I always, you know, and so my grandmother said it was the 12-year-old Wiggles, the eight-year-old Wiggles, the nine-year-old Wiggles. It just kept going and never stopped. And so my mother, in order to keep the peace at dinner, would say, would you like to go outside and get your Wiggles out? And I would say, yes, I would. And so I would go outside the glass sliding door. Like a dog has zoomies. And I would bounce around out there, like trying to get my sister to laugh, like trying to do stuff. And then I would come back in and
it would make me even more hyper. And my mom would say, and are they out? And I would be like, I don't know. And then, nope, I think there's a few more. And I would come back out and do it again and come back. Like a doggy has like a doggy has zoomies. God bless my siblings. It was actually funny. There was a period when one of my brothers was going through a phase and I was like, Rhonda, I'm just so worried. And she goes worried about what I'm like, how he's going to turn out. And she goes, what? I said, well, I mean, you know, like with all this going on. And she goes, what's up? You figured it out. And you were 10 times worse. Really? She was like, yeah, nightmare. Oh my God. Was there, do you remember the moment, if there was a moment where you
wanted to pursue something in the public? And then you thought, well, am I going to be able to live up to what I'm, I always worry about that with children. Yes. You want to drop the hammer on her? Yeah, go ahead, Tracy. Well, what was yours? Well, my question is minor letter, minor more like growing up in LA. Did you ever, while you were driving running, did you ever see like a school bus with kids giving each other massages? Go back. That was me. Wait, can I tell you, I want to get to your question, but can I tell you, because I feel like I told you this like waiting for our cars at an award show. But I'm going to tell you again, while other people get here, because it's so good. So Silver Spoons. Yes, huge fan. Okay, very big, very, very big
during my age group. And, you know, everybody loved Ricky. They loved Ricky Schroeder. I was like, no, I'm the Jason girl. You were the one that was teen beat, like that I would pull out and put on my wall. And then had to flip through a few pages before you got to me. I found it. And so, no. And then now, for some reason, whenever I'm asked like childhood crush, I can never get it right. And I say Justin, because I combine you with your sister. Yeah, because she never get that, Jay. Jay, you ever get that? You ever get that? Three times a week. Do you get that all the time? Really? Oh, I thought that was unique. No, no, I get Justin all. I will say he's really good about it. I've been with him many times with people and they'll go like, isn't that right,
Justin? You'll go, yep. Yeah. Oh my God, you don't even, he doesn't even flip you anymore. It doesn't. It's exhausting. But yes, you were, all these other people were so dumb. I mean, look, oh, that wasn't nice. I'd have those same, I'd have those same teen beat magazines looking at Jason too. Yeah. Yeah. That makes you feel awkward. You were like a teen, like a teen heart throb. Hey, Sean, hey, Sean, why don't you, Sean, why don't you walk us through that? Unbelievable. Unbelievable. Well, beautiful. Unbelievable. I know. I'm sorry. I'm terrible today. I want to get back to your question though. What's wrong with you? Yeah. So, I mean, good for you that you didn't, that you didn't
like, let that be a barrier and like, no, screw it. I don't want to, I don't want to have it fail or not be able to live up to her, you know. That still haunts me. There's a misconception that you could have been anything you wanted just because where you came from, but that's not how it's helped to you. Well, a couple of things, like if you think back to when we were younger, are we all in the same age range? Yes. Yes. Yes. The youngest. No, I'm 52. Okay. You are the youngest actually. Yeah. Of us three. Well, of us, of the three of us, but. But Will, you play the youngest, don't you? What's the oldest you can play, Will? What do you think the oldest is? I could stretch to 44 probably. Yeah. True. Yeah. You know what I mean? When you do that, I would say I would
give it a 16. Would my eyes get like this? Yes, you would. We call that smoke in the room. We call that smoke in the room, smoke in the trees. Tighten things up there. Yeah. Is that like a guy thing? No, we'd go along red carpets and we'd see other actors doing, we'd be like, oh, look, it's real smoky over there. Some guy be getting his phone. Hey, what's going on? I've had to learn how to not be an overpeaker on the carpet. Yeah, where you look over your shoulder. If you can see your tonsils, it's like a problem. Like, I'm like, oh my gosh. A big open mouth. Yeah, like turn it down to a two. Like I'm on like 11 on a carpet. Yeah, me too. You know, when I was growing up, when we were younger, being a child of was not what it is now. And a lot of people would change
their parents last name. And I think from a really young age, I was very aware of the fact that people were paying attention to me because I was an extension of someone they loved, as opposed to because of me. And because of that, I felt very compelled to figure out who I was, what I wanted, who I wanted to be. And that was my driving force. It was, you know, I mean, like growing, not challenging, that's the wrong word, but people, I used to have the metaphor that people would unlock the door and then sit on the other side, like how's she going to walk through, as opposed to being excited or like, Oh, this is so intriguing. But no, I mean, like, like everybody in this business, I, and especially at that time, I really had to like fight my way
through and and make a lot of failures. And yeah, you turned it into a positive. It sounds like where you knew that the bar was going to be higher than it's going to be more scrutiny. And so you really, yeah, it's arguably harder to do because you have so many more preconceived notions. But get it coming into the room as opposed to some other performer who comes in and does, has, there's no, yeah, there's nothing. Blank slate. Yeah. You know, I think the singing, like I actually wanted to be a singer. That was what I wanted to do. But guess what? Love myself. I love that song. You did it. You're a singer. So I, at 40 something, how old was I? I don't know. I did a movie where I sang. And let me tell you
that like the internal journey on that was real challenging. I'm facing that monster for myself. And I remember seeing God bless her. Lisa Marie, when Lisa Marie Presley, when she had come out with her first album and they obliterated her, they obliterated her. And I was like 16 years old at the time, I think. And I was like, Oh, that's not a good choice. Like, that's a hard path. And then yeah, I did the high note and I recorded songs and I made it through that terrible sort of internal monster of I'm never going to be my mom. And I realized I'm never going to be my mom. I'm never supposed to be my mom. You're never supposed to be your mom. And you killed it. And you killed it. It's so good. I love that song. I always used to say to
myself, yeah, I mean, you're a failure. Like you will never actually enter the Super Bowl in a halftime show in a helicopter. Like, babe, it's all, it's all going to be garbage. But you don't need to. But wait, what about, but didn't you have an embarrassing moment in high school or something where you sang? Yeah, I sang an acapella song and I started on the wrong key and my voice cracked. And I panicked and like froze. And then I tried again and messed it up again. And the entire audience started going, You can do it. You can do it. And my best friend at the time like came on stage and hugged me and I did it again. And then I was like, that's it. We're good. We've handled that little singing desire. I had, I talked about, I think I talked about it before. I had
it's the same kind of thing when I was doing a show called promises, promises, promises, promises. Yeah, promises. I'm Broadway, where I had a pressure. I didn't, I didn't do the pressure. You're asleep on the mic. Good night, Oscar. What was my cue? I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Open April 24th. The, um, the, uh, which theater? Which theater? Alaska. Alaska. Oh my God. I didn't even remember. I know, I know more than you. By the way, so I was seeing the pressure, the pressure of singing in front of all these people, a solo song is, is a lot. Like when everybody's looking at you to sing great. And then you have like the X factor, an American Idol and you know, the voice and all these singing competition shows
where people judge you for singing. And so all that pressure was, and it made me not be able to sing. And I was like, I got to quit. I quit. I got to get fired. Please fire me. I can't do this anymore. And then I went to therapy and I got over it and then I sang fine. But I know what you mean about like cracking or anything. It really is like traumatizing. There's nowhere to hide. Yeah, there's nowhere to hide. I will tell you now, like, there's nothing I like better. During filming of that movie, I was like, get me on a stage with a mic and just an audience, just get out there and listen to me. And if I'm not singing, I'm going to be talking. Listen, let me change my clothes so you can see another outfit. Look up. Does it sit there? Don't go to
人们会对你的歌唱评头论足。所以那种压力太大了，导致我根本唱不出来。当时我想，我得不干了。我不干了。我宁愿被炒鱿鱼。求求你炒了我吧。我再也受不了了。后来我去了心理诊所，走出了阴影，然后就能唱得很好了。但我懂你的意思，比如破音什么的。那真的就像经历心灵创伤一样。无处可藏。对，无处可藏。我现在可以告诉你，比如，没有什么比这更让我喜欢的了。在那部电影的拍摄过程中，我心想，快把我弄到有麦克风和观众的舞台上，去吧，听我唱。如果我不唱歌，我就会说话。听着，让我换身衣服，这样你们就能看另一套造型了。抬头看。它就呆在那儿吗？别去
the bathroom. I got more. It's like, I love this character. I love this character. I'm like, hold on a second. I got more to say. Nope. I didn't ask you a question. I'm answering myself. Thank you so much. Like I just want to like get in there and just keep going. Remember star search? Are we all old enough to remember stars? Do you remember Sam Smith? Sam Smith. Yes. Sam Smith. He was on search. Do you remember he was the one, not Sam Smith. Not Sam Smith. Sam. Oh God. He sang the Star Spangled Banner over the rainbow and Sam Harris. Sam Harris. Yeah, he was amazing. You do remember him. If I showed you him right now and he was like, Oh God, he's amazing. He was amazing. And this was Ed McMahon was the host, right? All by himself. He didn't have a co-host
洗卫生间。我还有呢。这就好比，我爱这个角色。我爱这个角色。我在想，等一下。我还有话要说。不。我没问你问题。我在自问自答。非常感谢。就像我只想融入其中然后继续讲下去。还记得《明星搜寻》(Star Search)吗？我们年纪都大到记《明星搜寻》了吗？你记得山姆·史密斯(Sam Smith)吗？山姆·史密斯。对。山姆·史密斯。他上过《明星搜寻》。你记得他是那个，不是山姆·史密斯。不是山姆·史密斯。山姆。噢天哪。他唱了《星条旗永不落》、《绿野仙踪》里的《跨越彩虹》还有山姆·哈里斯(Sam Harris)。山姆·哈里斯。对，他太棒了。你确实记得他。如果我现在给你看他的照片，他会觉得，噢天哪，他太棒了。他太棒了。当时埃德·麦克马洪(Ed McMahon)是主持人，对吧？就他一个人。他没有跟别人
with him. Did he? No. No. I remember that. Star search. That was like the first American Idol or something. Rosy O'Donnell was on search. Yeah. I was going to say it launched a bunch of people, I think. Yeah. Remember that? I should bring that back. Anyway. If you're at home, just google it right now. Go ahead. We'll take a second. Take a look. You can see we catch up what we're talking about. There you see Ed. You know, I was just talking about the other day. We are also the generation that remembers Ovaltine Tang. Yes. Tang. I'm trying to think of some of the other things I was trying to think of. All I drank was Tang. Tang. It was just water. Same here, college dude. I was just knee deep in Tang. Crushing it. The drink. What is your problem,
搭档主持，对吧？没有。没有。我记得那个。明星搜寻。那就像是美偶的鼻祖什么的。罗茜·欧唐纳(Rosie O'Donnell)上过《明星搜寻》。对。我本来想说它捧红了一群人，我觉得。对。记得吗？我应该把那个节目带回来。不管怎样。如果你在家，现在就去谷歌一下。去吧。我们花一秒钟。看一看。你能看到我们补上了我们刚才聊的话题。看到了吧，那是埃德。你知道，我前几天还在说呢。我们这一代人还记得阿华田和添宁(Tang)果珍。对。果珍。我正想搜肠刮肚地回忆其他的一些东西呢。我喝的全是果珍。果珍。里面只有水。我也是，大学哥们儿。我简直深陷果珍之中无法自拔。爽呆了。就是那个饮料。你到底有什么毛病，
dude? I can't have a conversation without being, you know what? You don't need to say poo. You don't need to say the other part. No, because I just got it. All right. So listen. Oh man. So wait. Tracy. Sorry, Tracy. First of all, that's my sister's name and I love her and I love you. All right. So listen. You're sister Tracy. I didn't know that. Yeah. Yeah. I'm a big fan of the podcast. So listen, I heard you on, so I heard you on Glenn and Duel. I listened to the podcast. I just ignore it. No, I get it. Believe me. I get it. I heard you on Glenn and Duel's podcast and you were fantastic. Thank you. I love them. I get it because you always talk about, we talk about this too, about how you love being home and you wished you wanted to go out more
哥们儿？我连个天都聊不成了，你知道吗？你不用说那个词。你不用说后面那个词。不，因为我刚才懂了。好吧。所以听着。噢天哪。所以等等。特雷西。对不起，特雷西。首先，那是我的妹妹的名字，我爱她，我也爱你们。好吧。所以听着。你的妹妹叫特雷西。我不知道这件事。对。对。我是这个播客的超级粉丝。所以听着，我听过你在，所以我听过你在格伦和杜尔(Glenn and Duel)节目里的表现。我听了那个播客。我只是不理它。不，我懂。相信我。我懂。我听过你在格伦和杜尔的播客里的表现，你棒极了。谢谢你。我喜欢他们。我懂，因为你总是谈论，我们也在谈论这个，关于你有多喜欢待在家，你其实希望当你收到酷炫地方的邀请时能多出去走走，但你通常不喜欢出门。这就好比想收到邀请又不想去的这种奇怪纠结。
when people invited you to cool places, but you don't often like to go out. It's like the weird tangle between wanting to be invited and also like not. Right. But I love this quote of yours, which is so great. You said, I'm an introvert who plays an extrovert in life. Yeah. I think that's true. Yeah. I think that's a lot of people. I'm the same. I would love to not go out every time it's time to go out. You don't play an extrovert. I don't even try. You don't do anything. You're an introvert who acts like an introvert. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Well, I mean, because Amanda, I got Amanda right there. It was just like the greatest extrovert. So I can just lay back, let her do all the talking and socializing. You're going to build in bad guys, what you got.
对。但我很喜欢你的这句名言，太棒了。你说过，我是一个在生活中扮演外向者的内向者。对。我觉得那是真的。对。我觉得很多人都这样。我也一样。每次该出门的时候，我都宁愿不出门。你可没在扮演外向者。我甚至都没试过。你什么都没做。你是一个表现得像个内向者的内向者。对。对。对。对。对。好吧，我的意思是，因为阿曼达，我身边就有阿曼达。她简直是个超级外向者。所以我可以退居二线，让她去包办所有的谈话和社交。你就要树立起坏警察的形象了，看你怎么办。
Don't worry about this. Yeah. You can travel with your bad cop. A little bit. Tracy, how are you single? I mean, it's kind of, you know what? Let's get back. No, let's get back to Will's question, because I'm broken. No, no, no. What guy wouldn't go nuts? You know what my theory is, Sean, I feel like I'm a unicorn. And so it's hard to find another one. Yeah. But I, it's not to say that I have had a boring life. You know what? The one thing that's true about all unicorns, what they're really horny. Hey guys. I can't believe we're left. I just snorted. That was the worst joke. It's one of the worst jokes. By the way, also, there's only one unicorn. That's the whole purpose of a unicorn. No, there's a village of unicorns. Will, we'll be right back.
别担心这个。对。你可以带着你的坏警察去旅行。稍微。特雷西，你怎么还是单身？我的意思是，这有点，你知道吗？我们回去吧。不，我们回到威尔的问题上来，因为我已经被整崩溃了。不，不，不。哪个男人不会抓狂呢？你知道我的理论是什么吗，肖恩，我觉得我是一只独角兽。所以很难找到另一只。对。但是，这并不是说我过着无聊的生活。你知道吗？所有独角兽身上都有一个共同点，那就是它们真的很好色。嘿，伙计们。我不敢相信我们还在。我刚才笑出了猪叫声。那是史上最烂的笑话。这是最烂的笑话之一。顺便说一句，而且，世界上只有一只独角兽。那是独角兽存在的全部意义。不对，那里有一个独角兽村。威尔，我们马上回来。
SmartList is supported by FanDuel. This year, the only app you need at your Super Bowl party is FanDuel, America's number one sports book. Download FanDuel now so you can bet Super Bowl 57 with a no sweat first bet. You'll get up to $3,000 back in bonus bets if your first bet doesn't win. FanDuel lets you bet on everything from the money line to point spreads to who will score a touchdown. You know, my cell phones in my pocket, I'm just like a regular civilian, but when I pull it out, I got a little lady luck on my side with FanDuel. I want to do like a FanDuel thing of my own because like Jason and Will have said like a million times they're coming to opening night for my show in Broadway. And I'm like, do I believe him? Do I not believe him?
SmartList由FanDuel赞助。今年，你在超级碗派对上唯一需要的应用就是FanDuel，美国排名第一的体育博彩公司。立即下载FanDuel，这样你就可以在超级碗57上进行无压力首注。如果你的首注没有赢，你将获得高达3000美元的奖金返还。FanDuel让你能对从胜负盘到让分盘再到谁能得分达阵的一切进行下注。你知道，我的手机就在我口袋里，我只是个普通老百姓，但当我把它掏出来时，身边就仿佛有了幸运女神相助，这就是FanDuel。我想自己搞一个FanDuel式的赌局，因为就像杰森和威尔说过上百万次的那样，他们要来看我在百老汇演出的首演之夜。而我在想，我是该相信他们呢？还是不相信他们？
I'd love to bet on that. Wouldn't that be kind of cool? The FanDuel sports book app is safe, secure and super easy to use. Best of all, you can get paid your winnings instantly. So join FanDuel today with promo code smartList to claim your no sweat first bet on Super Bowl 57. That's promo code smartList. Make every moment more with FanDuel, official sports book partner of the NFL. 21 plus exclusion supply. See show notes for full disclaimer. SmartList gets support from Visit Williamsburg. In Williamsburg, Virginia, there's never too much of a good thing because there's too many things to see, do, taste and experience. Whether you're a foodie, a golfer, a history buff, a shopaholic, an outdoor enthusiast, or a thrill seeker, you'll
我很乐意为此打个赌。那不是挺酷的吗？FanDuel体育博彩应用安全、可靠且超级好用。最棒的是，你可以立即拿到你的赢利奖金。所以今天就用促销代码smartList加入FanDuel，来申领你在超级碗57上的无压力首注吧。促销代码就是smartList。与FanDuel一起让每一个时刻都更有意义，FanDuel是NFL官方体育博彩合作伙伴。21岁及以上，条款适用。请参阅节目说明了解完整免责声明。SmartList获得Visit Williamsburg的大力支持。在弗吉尼亚州的威廉斯堡，美好的事物永远不会嫌多，因为这里有太多可以看、做、品尝和体验的东西。无论你是美食家、高尔夫球手、历史迷、购物狂、户外爱好者还是惊险刺激的寻求者，你都能
find what you came for. Come to Williamsburg to live life at your pace. From roller coasters to water parks, hiking and kayaking, Williamsburg is great for adventures of all kinds. And with over a dozen four plus star courses, it's become one of the East's premier golf destinations. Southern Comfort is just a taste of what their emerging food and beverage scene has to offer. From contemporary cuisine to the classics, fine dining to food on the go, and local craft breweries to a stunning winery, Williamsburg will satiate any appetite. Explore the grounds of America's first English settlement in Jamestown, or shop along the quaint streets of historic Williamsburg and Yorktown. Dig into the forensics of our country's earliest settlers, or experience a day in the life of one.
找到你所追求的。来威廉斯堡以你的节奏体验生活吧。从过山车到水上乐园，从远足到皮划艇，威廉斯堡是各种冒险的绝佳去处。这里拥有十多个四星级以上的球场，已成为东部首屈一指的高尔夫胜地之一。南方风情只是其新兴餐饮界的一小部分。从现代菜肴到经典美食，从精致餐饮到快餐便当，从本土精酿啤酒到令人惊叹的酒庄，威廉斯堡将满足任何食欲。探索美洲第一个英国定居点詹姆斯敦的土地，或者在历史悠久的威廉斯堡和约克镇古色古香的街道上购物。深入研究我们国家最早定居者的法医历史，或者体验他们的一天。
This just isn't a place to learn about our shared history. It's a place to live it. Williamsburg is the type of destination that you can come back to again and again and have a completely different experience. Go to visitwilliamsburg.com to start planning your trip today. And now back to the show. Let's talk about this first segue. I want to talk about your career and how great you are and how amazing Blackish was and that it's off the air now. And do you wish it was still on the air? Did it end at the right time? Did you, you know, and by the way, I remember hearing some story about how you used to make yourself cry as a kid and something like that. I did. To become a better actress or something like that. Well, yeah, my favorite thing to do is
这不仅仅是一个了解我们共同历史的地方。这是一个亲历历史的地方。威廉斯堡是一个你可以一次又一次重访，并获得完全不同体验的目的地。访问visitwilliamsburg.com，开始规划你今天的行程。现在让我们回到节目中。我们来谈谈第一个衔接话题。我想谈谈你的事业，你有多么出色，《喜新不厌旧》(Blackish)有多么了不起，而现在它已经停播了。你希望它还在播吗？它是在正确的时间结束的吗？你有没有，你知道的，顺便说一句，我记得听过一个故事，说你小时候怎么让自己哭泣，类似这样的话。我确实这么做过。为了成为一名更好的演员之类的。好吧，对，我最喜欢做的事情就是
like I would get upset about something and cry and then I'd just lay down and I would notice the tears were just puddling on the floor and then I would move myself as quickly as I could towards a mirror to just see what it looked like. Oh, look at that. Is that good? I don't know. It just sort of really trying to just see. Do you have a cry trick? Do you have a certain thing that you think about that can bring the tears? I just think of the most awful thing that like my worst nightmare of what could happen, somebody being gone. Yeah, I do the same thing. It's terrible. It's so bad to do to yourself. It's so bad for your soul. Like it is just terrible. I remember on Blackish we had a scene where that's that season when Dre and I were getting a divorce and then it all ends with like
我会为什么事情感到难过然后哭泣，接着我就会躺下来，我注意到眼泪正汇聚在地上形成一个小水坑，然后我会以最快的速度移向镜子，只想看看它看起来是什么样的。噢，看那个。那样好吗？我不知道。这其实就是真正地试图去看一看。你有什么哭泣的绝招吗？你有没有想什么特定的事情来催生泪水？我只是去想最糟糕的事情，比如我可能遇到的最大噩梦，某个人离去了。对，我也做同样的事情。太可怕了。对自己做这种事太糟糕了。对你的灵魂太糟糕了。这简直太糟糕了。我记得在《喜新不厌旧》里我们有一场戏，那是那一季，德雷(Dre)和我正在离婚，然后这一切以波(Bo)的父亲去世而告终。我不得不说波的父亲去世了，因为我一直在，我们拍了这场戏。我本该一团糟，歇斯底里地哭泣。然后我们拍的是喜剧。接着他们就说，好啦，我们拍下一场戏吧。然后我就想，我还是那样，爸爸死了。我感觉我灵魂深处的伤口依然敞开着。我还沉浸在情绪里没有出来。我的内心还在流血。但这简直是不可能的。比如你怎么，你知道的，我还沉浸在情绪里。刚才没人喊停。你在回家的路上还在哭。对。依然没有人喊停。这太荒谬了。你问了什么？你问我是不是觉得，你知道的，我在《女友们》(Girlfriends)演了八年，在《喜新不厌旧》演了八年。我知道。好辉煌的职业生涯。我的意思是，太疯狂了。两部大热剧。太疯狂了。我觉得
Bo's father dying. And I have to say Bo's father dying because I kept, we did this scene. I was supposed to be a mess crying hysterically. And then we're on a comedy. So then they were like, right, let's get to the next scene. And I was like, I'm still like that dad died. I'm like still like the wound is still open inside my soul. I haven't stopped rolling yet. I'm still bleeding inside. But it's like impossible. Like how do you, you know, I'm still rolling. No one said cut in there. You're still crying on the way home. Yeah. Still no one said cut. It's ridiculous. What did you ask? You asked if I think, you know, I did eight years on Girlfriends and eight years on Blackish. I know. What a career. I mean, that's crazy. Two big shows. It's crazy. And I think it
它结束的时间堪称完美。25|||《喜新不厌旧》完结的美妙之处在于我们知道它要完结了。所以我能够满怀对这一切的当下感走进最后一年、最后一季。并且真正去体验告别和结束的仪式感。而在《女友们》的时候，我们并不知道我们拍《女友们》的最后一集时就要结束了。我是导演，那是在编剧罢工期间。所以我们片场没有编剧。然后我们一下子就解散了。八年之后，没有庆功派对。什么都没有。所以能够以这种方式收尾真的是非常特别。这就好比每当我在家里举行聚会时，大家就会直接离开。而你甚至都不知道。等等，大家都去哪儿了？他们就像是，我们不喜欢那扇门。
was perfect timing for it to be done. The beauty of Blackish ending was we knew it was ending. So I was able to walk into the last year, the last season, so present to sort of all of it. And to actually get the ritual of saying goodbye and having it be over. Whereas on Girlfriends, we didn't know we ended the last episode that we shot of Girlfriends. I directed and it was during the writer's strike. So we had no writers on set. And then we just disappeared. There was no wrap party. There was no nothing after eight years. So this was really special to be able to sort of finish this way. And that's like whenever I have a gathering at my house, people just leave. And you don't even know. Wait, where did everybody go? They were like, we didn't like the door.
完成的时机堪称完美。《喜新不厌旧》结束的美妙之处在于我们知道它即将结束。所以我能够带着对这一切的全然呈现，走进最后一年、最后一季。并且真正享受到告别和结束的仪式感。然而在《女朋友们》这部剧里，我们拍完最后一集时根本不知道那是大结局。那是我导演的，当时正值编剧罢工，所以片场没有编剧。然后我们就这样解散了。没有杀青派对，八年之后什么都没有。所以能够以这种方式收尾真的非常特别。这就好比我在家里举行聚会时，大家总是悄悄离开，你甚至都不知道。等等，大家都去哪儿了？他们就像是，我们才不喜欢那扇门呢。
It's like dad's screeching tires. That's dad leaving. Wait, we didn't have a wrap party dad. But wait, wait. She said it's that's 16 years. I know. That's crazy, right? That is amazing. Television of episode television. I mean, that's so long. Hey, that's an incredible run. Hold on. I'm a black actress. Now, please continue. Okay, fair enough. I've done well, but let's compare. Yeah, yeah. For sure. For sure. Let's compare. Fuck it. Now, is it true that you when mom used to drive out of that driveway and she was away trying the, trying her dresses and her outfits and that's where fashion comes from? Because, you know, I do, I try to put it on. You put it on. I would take it. No, no, no,
就像爸爸开车时轮胎刺耳的尖叫声。那是爸爸要走了。等等，我们没有举办庆功派对呀爸爸。但是等等，等等。她说那是16年。我知道。太疯狂了，对吧？这太神奇了。电视剧的电视分集。我的意思是，时间太长了。嘿，这是一段不可思议的经历。等一下。我是个黑人女演员。现在，请继续。好吧，算你说的有理。我干得不错，但咱们来对比一下。对，对。肯定的。肯定的。咱们来对比一下。去他的。现在，是不是有这么回事，当妈妈把车开出那个车道时，她不在家，去试穿她的连衣裙和各种服装，这就是你时尚感的来源？因为，你知道的，我确实，我试着穿上它。你把它穿上。我会拿走。不，不，不，
it was even worse. I would literally, she would be pulling out of the driveway. I would go look, okay, she's pulling out great. And I would go into her bathroom into the closet and I would start taking everything I wanted, throwing it over my arm to move it into my closet for the time she was gone. So it's like I would open my closet as if these things were mine. And one time she came back, she had forgotten something. She was like, what are you doing? I was like, I am going to surprise you by organizing your closet. No way. No way. Did you really? That's amazing. I was like, I know, but go, I didn't get out of here. What did you forget? Did we get it for you? Stop it. That's hysterical. Wait, so, and is that,
情况还要糟糕得多。我literally，她正把车开出车道，我会去看，好吧，她开出去了，太棒了。然后我会走进她的浴室，走进衣橱，开始拿走所有我想要的东西，把它搭在胳膊上，在她不在家的这段时间里搬到我自己的衣橱里。所以这就好像我会打开我自己的衣橱，就好像这些东西本来就是我的一样。有一次她回来了，她落了点东西。她问，你在干什么？我说，我是来给你个惊喜，帮你整理衣橱的。绝不可能。绝不可能。你真的这么干了？太神奇了。我当时想，我知道，但快走，别在这儿碍事。你忘了什么？我们给你拿了吗？别逗了。这太爆笑了。等等，所以，这就是，
is that where, is your mom the inspiration for, for loving fashion or? I don't know. Because I follow you like a crazy person on Instagram and all of your like gorgeous, you always look so gorgeous in all the stuff you wear. I will always shop and there will always be dirty dishes in my same combination of both. Two things that are just true about me. But I stacked the dishes nicely because I'm extremely organized. Fashion was an armor for me. And looking back, I've actually realized it was one of the ways that I sort of protected myself from the world and fought microaggressions and racism. In the world that I lived in, I would navigate myself and my external appearance in a way that gave somebody an impression,
这就是你的灵感来源吗，你的妈妈是你热爱时尚的灵感来源，还是？我不知道。因为我在Instagram上像个疯子一样关注你，你所有的那些华丽穿搭，你在穿的所有衣服里总是看起来那么华丽。我总是会购物，而且我的水槽里也总是堆着脏盘子，这是我身上两者的完美结合。关于我的两个真实事实。但我把盘子叠得很整齐，因为我极度有条理。时尚对我而言是一种盔甲。回顾过去，我实际上意识到这是我保护自己免受世界伤害、对抗微歧视和种族主义的方式之一。在我生活的世界里，我会通过某种方式来驾驭自己和我的外在形象，给别人留下这样一种印象，
that and my articulateness. And I would sort of dive in in a way that like, you cannot belittle me. Not only my clothes telling you that, but, and also around men and whatever, like I just was able to sort of close myself in a way that told the world what I wanted them to know about me. And now it's a creative expression. What age do you think that, so that's such an interesting, what age do you think that you started, A, doing that, doing that, especially sort of against the microaggressions and B, did you become actually cognizant of the fact that you, that's what you were doing? I wasn't cognizant of that until now. Oh, wow. Because I started to think back, I can't remember who I was talking to and I was like, wait a minute, that's fascinating.
那就是我的口齿伶俐。我会以某种方式投入其中，让你无法轻视我。不仅我的衣服在告诉你这一点，而且在男人面前还是别的什么地方，我只是能够以某种方式保护自己，向世界传达我想让他们知道的关于我的一切。而现在它成了一种创意表达。你觉得你是在什么年龄，所以这是一个非常有趣的问题，你觉得你是在什么年龄开始，A，这么做的，采取这种做法，特别是用来对抗微歧视的，以及B，你什么时候开始真正意识到，那就是你在做的事情？我直到现在才意识到这一点。噢，天哪。因为我开始回想，我不记得我当时在跟谁说话，然后我就想，等一下，这太迷人了。
Because as I said, I've always loved clothes and so I was always a shopper. Like, but I, a lot of it was, there's a way you're not going to talk to me because I'm presenting myself in a particular manner. And I think that is a part of it. You know, as black people in this country, there is an idea of who we are, black and brown people. And so there's an external presentation that is expected that goes into, you know, respectability politics and all of these different things. There's a, you know, a way to sort of play into that. And I used clothing as one of those weapons for myself. I don't think I realized it, but it was from young, because I also, a person who was very independent from a young age, and I always looked older
因为正如我所说，我一直很喜欢衣服，所以我一直是个购物狂。但是，很大程度上，这是因为有一种方式能让你没法对我指手画脚，因为我是以一种特定的姿态展现自己的。我认为这也是其中的一部分。你知道，作为这个国家的黑人，对于我们是谁，黑人和棕色人种，有一种既定的看法。所以人们期望有一种外在的展现，这涉及到体面政治以及所有这些不同的方面。你知道，有一种去迎合这种期望的方式。而我把服装当作我自己的武器之一。我想我当时并没有意识到这一点，但这是从小就开始的，因为我从小也是一个非常独立的人，而且我看起来总是比实际年龄大。
than I was. I had to prove to people that I was younger, you know, and didn't have an ID or something. And some of it was my sort of stature and I've always been very, like I've always looked older for my age and sort of very articulate and clear in my communication. And so I don't know. But now it's just a way I spend my money. If you do, if this character doesn't hit the road, I'm gonna fuck it. There's a couple of characters that are behind me. You can't see them, but there's Madami Ver, who's the alcoholic acting coach. Related to bone at all. Yeah, I was just gonna say, Boney Ver. No, dare you fuckers. She's your idea, sweetheart. You're such a dear. I love the way you smile. It's wonderful. Yes. Madami Ver, she's all eyebrows. There's a picture behind me.
我得向人们证明我很年轻，你知道的，比如我没有身份证或者别的什么。其中一部分是我的身材原因，我一直都非常，就好像我看起来总是比实际年龄成熟，并且在沟通时非常清晰明了。所以我不知道。但现在这只是我花钱的一种方式。如果你，如果这个角色不走红的话，我就，去他的。我身后还有好几个角色。你看不到他们，但有马达米·韦尔(Madami Ver)，她是那个酗酒的表演教练。跟波有一点关系吗？对，我刚想说，波妮·韦尔(Boney Ver)。不，你们这群混蛋休想。她是你的主意，亲爱的。你太可爱了。我喜欢你笑的样子。太棒了。是的，马达米·韦尔，她全身都是眉毛。我身后有一张照片。
Apparently, I've done this my whole life and my mom one day, I was on the phone with my mom. She started talking in this weird voice. I was like, Mom, what are you doing? She was like, I'm just doing what you're doing. And I was like, I don't know what you're doing. I'm not sure. She's like, you always do this when you're telling stories. You just go into different voices. And I was like, do I? And yeah, so I apparently do this all the time. I love it. Let me ask you something about fashion. How do you know what is happening right now? Like, is there an agreed upon magazine that like, oh, if you see pictures of, let's say, how would you know that overalls are back? If it's in Vogue or if it's at the store?
显然，我一辈子都在这么做，有一天我妈，我和我妈在通电话。她开始用这种奇怪的声音说话。我说，妈，你在干什么？她说，我只是在学你说话。我说，我不知道你在干什么。我不确定。她说，你每次讲故事时都这样。你总是会突然切换到不同的声音。我说，我有吗？是的，所以显然我一直在这样做。我太喜欢了。让我问你一个关于时尚的问题。你怎么知道现在正流行什么？比如，是不是有一本大家都认可的杂志，比如，噢，如果你看到，比方说，你怎么知道工装裤又流行回来了？是通过《Vogue》杂志还是在商店里？
Asking for a friend. Here's the thing, though. So there's a difference between style and fashion, in my opinion. Thank you, amen. It's like a difference between spirituality and religion. Style is how you do things. It's sort of the, and fashion is the sort of what everybody is saying is in or out. Oh my God, Will, what are you about to say? Sorry, I'm just agreeing with you and I'm listening to you tell these two heathens. Keep going, Tracy. We're on the same page. Go ahead. And so for me, I really don't follow what's in and out. There are things that will tell you what the trends are and you'll start to see, but it's just like with anything. There's a zeitgeist and like certain things come in at the same time. And then there's somebody,
我在替一个朋友问。不过，事情是这样的。在我看来，风格和时尚是有区别的。谢谢，阿门。这就像精神与宗教的区别。风格是你做事的方式。这有点像，而时尚则是大家都在说什么是流行还是过时。噢天哪，威尔，你接下来要说什么？对不起，我只是在同意你的观点，我在听你给这两个异教徒上课呢。继续讲，特雷西。我们想法一致。说吧。所以对我来说，我真的不盲从什么是流行或过时。有些东西会告诉你潮流是什么，你会开始看到，但这就像任何事情一样。有一种时代精神，某些东西会同时流行起来。然后会有某个人，
there's, you know, an Anna Wintour, whomever, Edward Anifle, who will tell you like this year, the trend is overalls, pink lips and black nails. You know what I mean? But for me, I think that I should wear my clothes and they shouldn't wear me. So I follow what makes my heart sing. And the truth is I've been, the things that I wear have been, my body's been the same, the shape of my body's been the same slightly changed, but I still wear the same shapes, high waisted pants, wide leg trousers. I do love it overall. I love a big chunky shoe always have. You know, it's like those things are the same for me. The girls have so much more options. And the guys is like a suit. Not anymore. Not anymore. You can wear whatever you want.
会有，你知道的，像安娜·温图尔(Anna Wintour)或者爱德华·恩宁弗(Edward Enninful)这样的人，会告诉你今年流行工装裤、粉红色的嘴唇和黑色的指甲。你知道我的意思吗？但对我来说，我认为我应该驾驭衣服，而不是让衣服驾驭我。所以我遵循那些能让我的内心感到快乐的东西。事实是，我一直以来，我穿的东西，我的身材一直都是一样的，我身材的形状一直都差不多，只是略有变化，但我穿的版型依然是那些，高腰裤、宽腿裤。我确实很喜欢工装裤。我一直都很喜欢厚底大头鞋。你知道，这些东西对女生来说是一样的。女孩们有更多的选择。而男士们就只有一套西装。不再是这样了。不再是这样了。你可以穿任何你想穿的。
But like that's, I always, I always feel guilty when Amanda is like, you know, Sorry, I just heard my name. I was asleep for a second. I think guys have it so easy. Like you go to some like black tie event. Well, it's just a tuxedo. Great. I'm done in 10 minutes. But have you guys looked though, if you like notice now, like men are leaning into all these different spaces and wear skirts and I mean, didn't Brad pitch us wear a skirt for his press junket or something? I, you can wear whatever you want. Jason, I would love to see you in a skirt or some sparkles. Sure. Wait, didn't you run into Brad at the Oscars or something? And you were like totally
但这就好比，每当阿曼达说，你知道，对不起，我听到我的名字了。我刚才睡着了一小会儿。我觉得男士们太轻松了。比如你去参加一些黑领结派对。好吧，只要穿个燕尾服就行了。太棒了。我10分钟就搞定了。但你们有没有发现，如果你们现在注意的话，男人正在涉足所有这些不同的领域，穿裙子，我的意思是，布拉德·皮特(Brad Pitt)不是在宣传他的电影时穿了一条裙子吗？我，你可以穿任何你想穿的。杰森，我很想看你穿裙子或者亮片装。当然。等等，你不是在奥斯卡上碰巧遇到布拉德了吗？然后你整个人就完全
I, I, I ran into Brad. Brad did not see me when I saw him and he made eye contact. That's it. That's it. I love that. That is a good looking dude. It's like weird. Who's the other one? There was someone else recently and I was just like, what is wrong with that face? Why does it look like that? It's so pretty. Obviously it wasn't any one of us. Keanu Reeves. You know what? Yeah, no, it's okay. Well, we'll just. What was that, Sean? Hold on a second. Did you say Keanu Reeves? But is that pretty high on your list, Sean?
我，我，我碰到了布拉德。布拉德看到我的时候我没看到他，然后我们目光交汇了。就是这样。就是这样。我太喜欢了。那真是个帅哥。感觉好怪。另一个是谁？最近还有另一个人，我当时就想，那张脸是怎么回事？为什么它看起来是那样？太好看了。显然不是我们之中的任何一个人。基努·里维斯(Keanu Reeves)。你知道吗？对，没事。好吧，我们就。那是怎么回事，肖恩？等一下。你刚才说基努·里维斯？但这在你的名单上排名很高吗，肖恩？
Keanu, no. I think I love Keanu. I'm a huge fan of good looking guys, not my type. I, I mostly have dated black men. I date, I'm, but as a young in, it went from, it went like this. Jason. Yep. Yep. Then I think it was Keanu. Okay. Really? And never been, I've never been like a Brad Pitt fan. Like, like, like he was not like a crush from movies, but when you see him in person, it's like weird startling. Like you're just like, oh my God, what is happening with that face? Yeah. He's got, he's got, he's got tons of Riz.
基努，没有。我觉得我很喜欢基努。我是长得好看的男人的超级粉丝，但不是我的菜。我，我约会过的大多数都是黑人男性。我约会，我是，但作为一个年轻人，情况是这样的。杰森。对。对。然后我觉得是基努。好吧。真的吗？我从来都不是布拉德·皮特的粉丝。就像，就像他不是那种电影里的梦中情人，但当你亲眼见到他时，那种感觉怪异得让人震惊。就像你会想，噢天哪，那张脸到底是怎么回事？对。他身上有，他身上有，他身上有超强的魅力(Riz)。
He's really extraordinary. What's Riz? Riz. Is that what the kids are saying? I'm not explaining it to you guys. You guys don't know about Riz. You have to, because I'm a guest and I don't know. Riz is like what all the kids, like my kids say, they all talk about, talk about like a guy who's got like game or like charisma. That's amazing. I'm totally stealing that. Yeah. My kids hate it because I use it all the time and that they're really embarrassed, by the way, that I use them.
他真的非同寻常。什么是魅力(Riz)？魅力(Riz)。这是孩子们现在挂在嘴边的词吗？我才不跟你们解释呢。你们不知道什么是魅力。你们必须得懂，因为我是嘉宾，我不知道。魅力就像是所有孩子们，比如我的孩子们说的，他们都在谈论，谈论一个很有手段或很有个人魅力的男人。太神奇了。我完全要偷用这个词。对。我的孩子们讨厌我这么用，因为我老是说这个词，而且他们真的觉得很尴尬，顺便说一句，因为我在用。
Why don't you switch it to Ma? You guys got a lot of Ma. I actually kind of like that too. You know, but the charisma, you know, the thing is as you, as you, you know, you realize like that has nothing to do with sex appeal. Like the physical, this is not special to that. No, wait, wait. So, sorry, we, so keep going. So you went, it was Jason and Keanu, that it was never really Brad, although we all agree that Brad Pitt is incredible. Like objectively, it's like objectively, that's just like a, okay, nobody's going to dispute that. Yeah. Any great guy.
你为什么不换成妈(Ma)呢？你们有很多“妈”。其实我还挺喜欢那个的。你知道，但是个人魅力，你知道，事实是随着你，随着你，你知道，你意识到，这跟性感毫无关系。那种外在的，这并不是他的专利。不，等等，等等。所以，对不起，我们，所以继续。所以你经历了，那是杰森和基努，然后从来都不是布拉德，尽管我们都一致认为布拉德·皮特太不可思议了。客观来讲，这就好比，客观来讲，那就是，好吧，没有人会对此有异议。对。任何好男人。
Keep going. Now you talk about Riz. You got a lot of Riz and I didn't know Tracy. And I didn't know, I was like, why doesn't she have her own podcast? And now you do. And it's called I am America. It is very different from a Riz podcast though. Wait, what, tell me, when did it start and how is it? It's not, it's not a Ma podcast. It's not a thing.
继续。现在你谈到了魅力。你很有魅力，而我之前不了解特雷西。我当时还想，她为什么没有自己的播客？而现在你有了。它叫《我是美国》(I am America)。不过这跟魅力播客很不一样。等等，什么，告诉我，它是什么时候开始的，感觉怎么样？它不是，它不是一个“妈”播客。不是那回事。
Now we're going to make it a thing. Just pick a different syllable, bro. I'm embarrassed in the way that my kids are. I can't wait to see those boys again. Jason's about to dab for fuck's sake. Did I do it right? No, you did not. I don't even know. That looked like something from cheer camp.
现在我们要把它变成一个热梗。换个音节吧，兄弟。我感到尴尬，就像我孩子们觉得尴尬那样。我等不及要再见到那些男孩了。杰森简直要跳嘻哈舞(dab)了，看在上帝的份上。我动作对吗？不，你做错了。我甚至都不知道那是什么。那看起来像是啦啦队训练营里的动作。
Hi, ready? Okay. Yes. I have a podcast that is January 31st that I'm very excited about. It's called I am America. And we meet people who are redefining their own identity and the idea of community. And what I think is the possibility of our country. And the thing that's so exciting to me is it's a version of, it's the best of our country and a version that I just don't hear enough of around people that are looking to belong and end up creating a sense of belonging for so many others.
嗨，准备好了吗？好的。是的。我有一个1月31日上线的播客，对此我非常兴奋。它叫《我是美国》。我们在节目中结识那些正在重新定义自身身份和社区概念的人们。还有我认为代表着我们国家无限可能的人。最让我兴奋的是，这是我们国家最好的一面，也是我听到的关于那些渴望归属感并最终为许多其他人创造归属感的人的故事还不够多的一个版本。
And so they tell their own stories. It's some people you might know, some you don't know at all. Deanna Van Buren, who is one of very few black female architects. A man by the name of Tony Hillary, who started Harlem Grown in New York. And his beautiful story and realizing that it takes a lot to grow children. And it's not what you expect. Keir Gaines, who's a therapist, a black male therapist and really works with people. And so I then sort of create context and so much of what happens
所以他们讲述他们自己的故事。其中有些人你可能认识，有些你完全不认识。迪安娜·范布伦(Deanna Van Buren)，他是极少数的黑人女性建筑师之一。一个叫托尼·希拉里(Tony Hillary)的人，他在纽约创办了哈莱姆成长项目(Harlem Grown)。他那美丽的故事让我意识到抚育孩子们需要付出很多。而且这跟你想象的完全不一样。基尔·盖恩斯(Keir Gaines)，他是一位治疗师，一位黑人男性治疗师，真正致力于帮助人们。所以我随后会去构建背景，而在这个国家，
for the black and brown stories in this country is they're decontextualized. And we don't get to really hear the context and the fertility, the sort of depth of their stories. And so I do the intro and the outro and I sort of frame and give context to their stories. And I'm just very excited about it. Every time I listen and the editing process, I just a bit, I move to tears and how beautiful these stories and these people are. So it's been really fun for me. I love that. That's great. I can't wait to hear that.
很多黑人和棕色人种的故事都是脱离背景的。我们无法真正听到他们故事的背景和丰富性，以及故事的深度。所以我负责开头和结尾，我为他们的故事搭建框架并提供背景。对此我感到非常兴奋。每次我聆听和参与剪辑过程时，我都会被这些故事和这些人的美好感动得热泪盈眶。所以这对我很具有成就感。我喜欢这样。太棒了。我迫不及待想听了。
Yeah. Yeah. It's you say we's that you by yourself or just you and your team of me and my team. We put together a really beautiful team that honestly is just as beautiful of a tapestry as the people we're interviewing. Just amazing people doing our sound design and and our producer Nicole Hill. It's really been a really fulfilling process for me. That's great. So great. I love it. I can't wait to hear it.
对。对。你说“我们”，那是只有你自己还是你和你的团队？我和我的团队。我们组建了一个非常棒的团队，老实说，它就像我们采访的人们一样，是一幅美丽的织锦。做我们音效设计的人还有我们的制片人妮可·希尔(Nicole Hill)，都是极棒的人。对我来说，这真的是一个非常充实的过程。太棒了。太棒了。我喜欢。我迫不及待想听了。
Well, you know, we've taken up too much of your time. I love people with two names. I love people with three names, even more Tracy Ellis Ross. You're amazing. Thank you for being here. This has been so much fun. I am a huge fan. You know how much I love you so much.
好吧，你知道的，我们占用了你太多时间。我喜欢名字有两个字的人。我更喜欢名字有三个字的人，特雷西·埃利斯·罗斯(Tracy Ellis Ross)。你太棒了。谢谢你能来。这真的太有趣了。我是你的超级粉丝。你知道我有多么爱你。
God, you're so funny. You're so hilarious. Yeah. God, you are. You are. You are. It's so great to meet you and to talk to you. And you've got a ton of Riz.
天哪，你太有趣了。你太滑稽了。对。天哪，你真的是。你是。你是。很高兴能认识你并和你交谈。而且你浑身散发着无尽的魅力。
I'm just going to leave you with that last little bit of ma. Thank you. I know you're busy with all the stuff, the products you got going on and the lines and the things. Yeah. Pattern beauty. It's been really fun. It's a really fun thing getting to this point in one's career where you actually can start creating things
我就用最后这一点“妈”来跟你道别吧。谢谢你。我知道你现在忙于各种事务、你手头的各种产品和产品线。对。Pattern beauty。这真的很有趣。当你的职业生涯走到这一步，你实际上可以开始创造东西，
and not just waiting for the next job. Yeah. It's really exciting. Not everybody gets to get here. So it's fun. Yeah. Well, you worked your buns off. So kudos to you. Congratulations. No, no, I still have really, really nice buns.
而不只是在等待下一份工作，这种感觉真的很奇妙。真的让人兴奋。不是每个人都能走到这一步的。所以这很有趣。是的。好吧，你付出了百分之百的努力。所以向你致敬。恭喜。不，不，我依然有着非常非常棒的臀部。
Thank you. Yeah. Sweet buns. Hot buns. Sweet buns. Yeah. That's what I was going to say. Thank you, buns.
谢谢。对。甜甜的面包。热腾腾的面包。甜甜的面包。对。我本来想这么说。谢谢你，面包。
Okay. Amazing. All right, honey. Bye. Thanks, Tracy. Thank you so much. Hope to see you soon. Bye, sweetie. How great is she? Jason, have you ever met her?
好吧。太棒了。好了，亲爱的。再见。谢谢你，特雷西。非常感谢。希望很快能再见。再见，甜心。她有多棒？杰森，你见过她吗？
I have. Yeah. Oh, yeah. Super duper nice. Tracy. Well, what about you? Had you met her before? I've never met her before.
我见过。对。哦，对。超级无敌好。特雷西。威尔，你呢？你以前见过她吗？我以前从未见过她。
Isn't she unbelievably funny? She's so cool. She truly does have charisma. Oh, my God. Yeah. Off the charts. I think she could talk about like in, I know Dana Carvey was on a recent show.
她是不是好笑得难以置信？她太酷了。她真的很有个人魅力。噢，天哪。对。好得离谱。我觉得她可以谈论，我知道达纳·卡维(Dana Carvey)最近上过一个节目。
It's like she could do like sketch, like it'd be a super huge sketch comedy person. Oh, my God. She is not slow. Yeah. She's so fucking witty and. She's so witty and so funny. And the energy.
就好像她可以做那种小品，她会是一个超级了不起的小品喜剧演员。噢，天哪。她脑子转得可快了。对。她太他妈机智了，而且。她太机智太有趣了。而且能量满满。
And you know what? Like a lot of people, there's this equation, I think, like that suits certain, you know, names and celebrities or whatever. That if your name equals joy, I think you got something. And I think her name, I think just, she just equals joy.
你知道吗？就像很多人一样，我觉得有一个公式，适合某些名字和名人的公式。如果你的名字等于快乐，我觉得你就掌握了某种秘诀。我觉得她的名字，我觉得只要，她就等于快乐。
I think she's so joyful. And you're saying when you hear her name, when you hear her name, you think joy. Yeah. For sure. Don't you? What do you think people think of when they hear your name?
我觉得她是一个充满快乐的人。你是说当你听到她的名字，当你听到她的名字时，你会想到快乐。对。肯定的。难道你不会吗？你觉得别人听到你的名字时会想到什么？
My name just, I got to take a potty break or something. Yeah. Oh, Sean. Hey, Sean, I got a shit. No, people, it's also good. Not too much stomach. It's a good feeling. Also, Sean is another person just like Tracy Ellis-Roster.
我的名字，我得去上个厕所什么的。对。噢，肖恩。嘿，肖恩，我要拉屎了。不，大家，这也挺好。肚子别装太多。这感觉不错。另外，肖恩也是那种像特雷西·埃利斯·罗斯一样的人。
You're like, that person brings good positive energy and I think laughter and it's fun and good. Seriously, they do. That's how I feel when I think of you. Oh, well, that's very nice. Yeah. There's no butt coming here, huh? I know.
你会觉得，那个人带来了美好的积极能量，我想还有笑声，既有趣又好。说真的，他们确实如此。这就是我想到你时的感觉。噢，好吧，这太好了。对。这后面可没有“但是”吧，哈哈？我知道。
I thought I was waiting for a big butt. But we didn't get a chance to talk about, that's very sweet, Will. I love you guys very much. I love you very much. So, but we didn't get a chance to talk about all of her, you know, products and all the products of the products, which are called.
我还以为会有一个巨大的“但是”呢。不过我们没机会谈论她的所有，你知道的，产品和各种产品，它们的名字叫。
Oh, you're talking about the, bye, products. Bye. Why do you have to make it sound like someone's getting stuck in a vice? I do, or Will. Bye, hey, hey, hey, bye. Bye. Smart, less.
噢，你在说，拜拜，产品。拜。你为什么非要把它说得好像有人被卡在老虎钳里了一样？我就是这样，或者威尔。拜，嘿，嘿，嘿，拜。拜。SmartLess。
Smart, less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barberco. Smart, less. Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus
SmartLess由迈克尔·格兰特·特里(Michael Grant Terry)、罗布·阿尔贾夫(Rob Armjalf)和贝内特·巴尔伯科(Bennett Barberco)100%有机手工打造。SmartLess。我们的下一期节目将在两周后发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方收听，或者现在就可以在亚马逊音乐(Amazon Music)上抢先收听，也可以通过订阅苹果播客(Apple Podcasts)或Wondery App上的Wondery Plus来抢先收听无广告版。人生苦短，其中充满了许多有趣的问题。幸福究竟意味着什么？我该如何充分利用我在地球上的这段时光？到底什么才是最好的麦片？这些便是我每周播客《贾斯汀·朗的人生苦短》(Life is Short with Justin Long)中试图解答的问题。如果你在寻找深刻哲学问题的答案，
in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. Life is short, and it's full of a lot of interesting questions. What does happiness really mean? How do I get the most out of my time here on earth? And what really is the best cereal? These are the questions I seek to resolve on my weekly podcast, Life is Short with Justin Long. If you're looking for the answer to deep philosophical questions
比如生命的意义是什么，我其实帮不上忙。但我坚信，通过向他人学习，我们确实丰富了这里的体验，这就是为什么在每一期节目中，我都喜欢与演员、音乐家、艺术家、科学家以及更多不同类型的人探讨他们如何充实地过好每一天。我们探讨他们在辉煌时刻的感受，有时更重要的是，还有他们职业生涯低谷时的感受。
like what is the meaning of life, I can't really help you. But I do believe that we really enrich our experience here by learning from others, and that's why in each episode, I like to talk with actors, musicians, artists, scientists, and many more types of people about how they get the most out of life. We explore how they felt during the highs, and sometimes more importantly, the lows of their careers.
我们讨论他们在一些艰难时期是如何保持快乐的。但说实话，这其实大多只是朋友之间关于重要事情的有趣闲聊。比如如果你有一种以你名字命名的三明治，里面会放些什么？在任何你获取播客的地方关注《人生苦短》。你还可以在亚马逊音乐或Wondery App上收听无广告版。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
We discuss how they've been able to stay happy during some of the harder times. But if I'm being honest, it's mostly just fun chats between friends about the important stuff. Like if you had a sandwich named after you, what would be on it? Follow Life is Short wherever you get your podcasts. You can also listen ad-free on the Amazon Music or Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们探讨了他们在一些艰难时期如何保持快乐。但老实说，这大多只是朋友之间关于重要事情的有趣闲聊。比如如果你有一种以你名字命名的三明治，里面会放些什么？请在各大播客平台关注《人生苦短》。你也可以在亚马逊音乐或Wondery应用上免广告收听。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。